let me just bring up one thing quickly
you've been coming on the show for many
many many years and you do this one
thing consistently which is you say
we're gonna see a clip and then I throw
to what I think is a clip and it turns
out to be a clip from this terrible et
ripoff right called Mack and me can you
have done this to me I think about 30
times I know I just fight but I just
wanted to bring it up because we are now
talking about you've been in big movies
but this is a Marvel movie right and
this is something it's serious yes and
that's why I I feel like I'm glad you
said it because I have to address it I
can't obviously and it kills me and I
feel dumb that I'm not gonna be able to
show it this time but obviously Marvel
in this whole machine they get pretty
upset if you don't
so do that yeah and we didn't wanna
upset like the Nerds and the people and
the real hardcore nerds it's a hardcore
fairy nerds
yeah the hardcore fans that pay my rent
nerds
know what I didn't want to we don't want
to whatever freak them out we upset them
so this is do we address this is you
learning from Michael Douglas let's take
a look
we've learned about the suit but you've
yet to learn about your greatest allies
the ants loyal brave and your partners
on this job
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so as you can see I it doesn't go
according to plan I have a lot to learn
why don't we show the real clip from the
highly anticipated Marvel movie ant-man
you've learned about the suit but you've
yet to learn about your greatest allies
the ants loyal brave and your partners
on this job
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you I'm so excited that everybody
seems so excited for the movie yeah yeah
you were right about the effects they
are spectacular knotch